[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings there is
major news this morning in the
years-long fight for equal pay by the
women's national soccer team the team
and the u.s soccer federation have
reached a settlement for a total of 24
million dollars in their equal pay
discrimination lawsuit the players sued
the federation back in 2019 citing
unequal pay compared with their male
counterparts we're joined now by players
there's megan repino and alex morgan
hello along with cindy parlo cohn she's
a president of the u.s soccer federation
good morning one and all we're very
excited to have you here this morning i
want to start with the breaking news
alex in particular hello guys can you
put into words what it feels like this
morning
when we talk about you finally reach the
settlement after fighting this long and
standing up for yourselves put into
words what this feels like megan could
you start us off
oh i'll do my best but um it's a little
bit surreal to be honest um obviously
we've been in this for a long time and
um you know coming from a long history
of of women that have fought to put this
sport in a better place so i mean i
think pride comes to mind um just
incredibly proud of
the women on this team and all all the
women who this lawsuit represents
our greater extended team
obviously we have you know lawyers and
um strategists and media people to help
us um everybody's been in our corner the
entire time i feel like the thing i look
look forward to and i'm really proud of
is that you know the justice comes in
the next generation never having to go
through what we went through it's it's
equal pay across the board from here on
out and i'm looking forward to
continuing to grow the sport and to uh
have this be a moment we look back on uh
that signals a a new us soccer that we
can all be extremely proud of
alex the suit originally asked for 66
million dollars you settled for 24
million why did you all decide on that
amount and why now
uh we really got full back pay on
you know everything non-world cup
bonuses and i think
an important piece of it was equalizing
not only
the
money moving forward but the world cup
bonuses as well and working with u.s
soccer and the men's players association
to find a way to equalize that prize
money moving forward obviously we still
con fifa for that um but this is a huge
step and mending that relationship with
u.s soccer is also a big piece to that
and we felt we feel very
comfortable and happy and proud with the
moment that we've got to right now
because it is a huge win for
us for women's sports
for women in general
and it's a moment that we can all
celebrate right now
hey cindy it's tony here picking up on
what alex just said about mending the
relationship with u.s soccer what is the
state of that relationship after now
almost six years of fighting essentially
the women sued their employer
alleging discrimination uh so what is
the state of the relationship and also
what motivated u.s soccer to come back
to the negotiating table when you could
have kept pressing this in court
well you know as a former player myself
i have huge motivation to move past this
contentious litigation
and so i just want to move the sport
forward and like alex said this is a
huge win for everyone this is a win for
the players u.s soccer the sport women
in sports and just women in general so
for me it's about moving forward
together and really focusing on what's
important in growing the game both here
at home and across the world
cindy i want to i want to go right back
to you the settlement is contingent on
the new collective bargaining agreement
and as a former nfl player i understand
that aspect of it but what does that
look like when it comes to the contracts
does that mean that the bonuses will be
the same as the men's contracts
yeah so everything will be the same
structure
obviously each team can have a
difference because the teams have
different needs
but we're trying to do it in a very open
and transparent way inviting both sides
to the to each other's negotiations
so but moving forward everything will be
equal including fifa world cup prize
money
how will it affect you know the back
play the back pay for the other players
will there be backstage for other
players
okay well you know the back pay is
actually going to be within the statue
of limitation and for the players that
that played during that time period so
it might not
it might not be for the players who have
only joined recently
but that will be in legal terms but i
think the biggest win that we can look
at today is equalizing um is equal pay
moving forward and so yeah the back pay
is going to help some of us players who
have been on the team for a lot more
years but at the same time this is going
to benefit those younger players much
bigger can you talk in a little more
detail megan this might be best directed
to you about the benefits
for that next generation of talent so
the girls in the pipeline who want to
make the women's team
yeah i mean i think that the biggest
thing as an athlete is you always want
to have the ability to focus on your
sport with everything that you have it
takes a sort of mental emotional and
spiritual commitment uh to be a
professional athlete and you know as you
know we're we're up right now i think
it's 3 50 uh pacific time
we've spent countless hours on the
lawsuit or cba negotiations or whatever
it is
i think the the biggest um you know
piece of little legacy that that us us
of this generation can take is that the
players coming up next will have a much
better ability to just play and with
that comes
you know them probably being way better
than we ever were that's that's kind of
the goal um obviously equal pay moving
forward um not just from a base salary
perspective but from the bonuses as well
um this team has proven um time and
again to be incredibly successful on the
world stage on the biggest stage in the
world cups that's what everybody aspires
to and there'll be a much bigger prize
and pot of money going forward but i
think the working conditions as well
that's something that we settled a bit
ago but it's you know the types of uh
charter flights that we're taking it's
the hotels that we're staying in it's
our support staff it's everything a to z
the facilities the facilities does this
mean you'll be paid the same as the men
does this mean guys you'll be paid the
same as the men going forward
it does yes equal on all fronts um
including world cup bonuses
and megan i think you you you found what
is a joyous and unifying note to end on
there that this means that the women can
just play just play just play which is
ultimately what it's all about uh and i
think we should end on that note it's a
beautiful one this is a big day for all
of us for all of you megan rupino alex
morgan cindy parlo cohen thank you very
much for being here megan i love your
hair i love it thank you appreciate
y'all
all right bye you guys